I don't think having a president that
has taken like concrete steps to prevent
the transfer of power which he did with
the electorate sham which he did with
Pence and which he did with trying to
capitalize on the j6 violence a
president that's taken concrete steps
towards uh cing the government
essentially I don't know why that guy
we'd say well you know it's Trump he
does Trump things the guard rails held
I'll probably hold next time when we say
we shouldn't do you mean that he should
be actually barred from office I'm just
talking about support for I don't think
Republicans should should support Trump
you lose your incumbent advantage the
guy's obviously self-destructive he's
destructive the political party itself
like um you think he should be on the
ballot um you think there's a case to be
made to remove him from the ballot I
think there's a case to be made but man
the phrasing for as much as our uh
governmental founding fathers and
everybody else you know wrote nice
amendments and wrote nice the
Constitution some of the phrasing is
very very very and the uh section three
um the the the not requiring any type of
actual conviction um I don't have a
strong feeling on it I will say I'm very
interested in reading the majority
opinion from the Supreme Court I
seriously doubt the Supreme Court is
going to uphold that states should be
able to decide if they leave them off
The Ballot or not um I think for the
political future of the United States
it's probably not healthy that the
leading opposition candidate is now
going to be barred from the ballot it's
probably not healthy for us um because
because then what you want talk about
threats to democracy that would be a
pretty serious one applied across the
board by the way it would be however
like that threat to democracy was earned
by Donald Trump and the conservatives
that supported him I think conservatives
made a dangerous gamble when they threw
into office and now like all of the
Fallout from that is is something that
we all As Americans have to deal with I
mean I I I think that the the
unprecedented legal theory that a state
can simply Barrow somebody from the
ballot on the basis of in an informal
way believing that he is quote unquote
an insurrectionist uh is is pretty wild
I mean that's that that we can say it's
pretty well but there is an amendment in
the Constitution the 14th amendment that
says that if they have engaged in this
they shall not be or you shall I don't
remember the phrasing because it doesn't
require conviction but it's a
self-executing arguably thing for
getting into constitutional law I mean
there there there are a number of
Provisions that that suggest that this
is number one not self-executing the
minority opinions in the in the Colorado
Supreme Court case are are pretty
thorough the the number one contention
which is that this is not self-executing
uh because other elements are not
self-executing uh that ignores
subsequent actual law that that happened
I mean the Congress passed a law for
example in 1872 defining who was an
insurrectionist who is not an
insurrectionist for perses of elections
in 1994 Congress passed a law that
specifically defined Insurrection as a
criminal activity so that somebody could
theoretically be convicted of
insurrection and therefore ineligible to
run office it is unlike say the the the
analoges that are used by the majority
opinion like age obviously this is not
the same thing we can all tell what
somebody's age is by looking at the
birth certificate I can't tell whether
somebody's an insurrectionist without
any reference to a legal statute or
definition of the term I would also say
be careful with that because remember
one of Trump's first like big political
actions was challenging Obama's birth
certificate well and and I thought that
was dumb at the time but in any Cas I
like that you both said 100% chance that
Trump will try to go for third term and
0% chance which statistic term he's done
man are you kidding he would want to
Trump's going to walk around hands up
high and like I'm a two-term president
I'm the only President since Grover
Cleveland he would know but but since
Grover Cleveland who served two
non-consecutive terms I kicked Joe Biden
out of office and I kicked Hillary
Clinton out of off dude would be like
he'd be living large you kidding he
doesn't want the presidency anymore
after that I just think that the I think
it's scary that like Donald Trump it
feels like for all of the accusations
that are made sometimes against
Democrats like Biden is ordering uh
Garland to investigate Donald Trump and
blah blah blah uh it seems like Donald
Trump would actually do that with his
would give them orders he didn't he
didn't he he kind of did though right um
so for instance with um Jeffrey Clark uh
Jeffrey Clark went to Rosen and Donahue
and said Hey listen uh I need you guys
to sign off on a letter that we're going
to use essentially to bully States into
overturning their elections by saying we
found significant election fraud and
part of that threat was Jeffrey Clark
saying listen if you're not going to do
it Rosen uh you know Trump's going to
fire you and just make me the acting
attorney general that was a threat that
he carried and I think Trump repeated
that threat in a meeting later on that
was only rebuked when I think like half
the White House staff said if you do
this were resigning okay so that's a
slightly different topic because now
you're getting into all the election
Shenanigans and all this but I'm saying
he threaten to fire his acting attorney
general if he wouldn't carry the same
plot for essentially like if Trump could
order his doj to do something would he
um it's not Beyond The Pale for him
right it's not Beyond The Pale for him
to order them to do it and then it's not
Beyond The Pale for them to reject him
doing that which is the story of his
entire Administration whereas Joe Biden
order doj to do things and then they
just do them well I'm not we can get
into specific there um I I just I it
this is one of the big problems that I
have with I mean for example all the
talk about Trump Tyrant Trump executive
power I mean Joe Biden has used
executive power in ways that far outrip
every president has been stretching and
stretching and stretching executive
power Jo Joe Biden is going like Joe
Biden has gone well beyond anything
Trump even remotely attempted to
maintain via just pure executive power
and actually Trump's use of executive
power is nowhere near even what Obama's
was Trump inability to get border policy
pass literally had him using executive
power to to March the military down to
the border to do border policy I mean I
mean Joe Biden literally used the
occupational safety and Hazard
Administration to try to cram down vax
mandates on 80 million Americans that's
insane he literally said I cannot
relieve student loan debt and then tried
to
relieve hundreds of billions of dollars
in yeah but what happened to that it got
struck down by the Supreme Court and
then they still did it they still did it
Biden brags about
it for what he for what he was able to
for what he was able to relieve which I
think were related to particular type
student loone debt but I'm just saying
that like well the guard rails are
holding with Biden as much as they're
holding with Trump the only difference
is is that once Biden you know exhausts
his executive power he's not running
around like lying to people or trying to
extort people or trying to and concoct
insane schemes well I mean so here
here's the way I would think of this
think of the guard rails holding as the
filter okay meaning like the the coffee
is in the filter some of it's you know
what what you want is going to get
through and all the stuff the guard
rails prevent the other stuff from
getting through now the question becomes
what liquid are you pouring into the
filter okay meaning so if I if I'm if if
the filter exists if the guard rails
hold and if Donald Trump can't steal
elections what's the policy that comes
through the other end of the filter the
policy I get from Donald Trump on the
other end of the filter is a bunch of
stuff that I like the policy that I get
from Joe Biden on the other end of the
filter is a bunch of I don't so
that's the basic calculation okay so so
then the idea is essentially that Donald
Trump's rhetoric is insane but we don't
care um Donald Trump would probably try
to steal an election if he could but he
probably won't be able to um he's not
going to do it again I told you he's not
you don't you don't think he has any why
not because he won't be eligible to be
on the ballot in I mean by the way you
want to talk 14th Amendment that's where
the 14th amendment applies okay that
that's where it actually applies meaning
you cannot he is not qualified to be on
the ballot in 20128 if he is the
president of the United States states
can literally in self-executing fashion
take him off the ballot just like he's
past the age of 35 once you have been
president two times you're no longer
eligible to be president of the United
States why then you to have a strong
little keep off the B why the why would
the 14th Amendment stop if he thought
vice president Pence could unilaterally
decide the outcome of the election that
when he's not on the ballot so so now
now your theory is that he's going to
get he's going to get reelected and then
in 2028 he's not even going to be on the
ballot and he's going to direct his new
vice president K Lake to Simply declare
him president of the United States when
he has not been on a ballot I don't know
what the I don't know what the scheme
would be I think we can kind of like
laugh and say there's no scheme we could
even concoct but I think like with the
machine gun he's going to walk I think I
think the issue though is that like the
idea of electing another president that
has tried to circumvent the peaceful
transfer of power using extra legal
means and then pretending like we can't
concoct a sing
scheme that he could try to circumvent
um other legal processes to have a third
term or to have a longer term or to
install who he wants as the next
president I just when a when a person
has already shown you who they are and
with every single person around him
agrees with that when every single
person that's worked with him save for
the what Sydney pal uh Eastman and
Giuliani which I don't think even I
don't think anybody would want to throw
their lot in with those three um it just
seems wild to me that we would say like
yeah we're just going to go ahead and
trust this guy with another ter of
president but like he can't run for a
third term so it's fine when there's
like 50 million and other things I'll
make you the case that if you want him
not to make election trouble you should
elect him president in the next election
cycle and then he will be ineligible
that okay I find that to be aolly
unconvincing argument but
okay